Well, I'm really excited to bring our next guest
to the desk because he's spent the last year
doing something very special.
It all started when he lost his office job last summer
and days later, he created, "I Want to Mow Your Lawn".
It's a charity offering free lawn care to veterans
and seniors in his New Jersey community.
And that was just the start of a movement
for mowing.
From one man and one mower, it's grown to guess what,
115 volunteers
across 31 states.
Wow, that's a movement.
(audience applauding)
So, I saw this story and I literally can't believe it.
He's actually here right now.
Please welcome Brian Schwartz.
In the flesh.
(audience applauding)
The moment where you lose your job,
how did you turn that into looking outwards and wanting
to take care of others?
I definitely felt like my world was caving in
and you know,
I just, I went outside to mow my own lawn,
just to clear my mind,
just think about life, like what's next.
And I found it to be just a form of therapy.
So I just packed up my mower
into my family jeep, drove around,
and just kept going.
Good social distant, yard work, free of charge.
Oh, I know you have been,
well, I think about what you did,
which is just one little thing, mowing the lawn,
but it started a movement now even inspired
so many other people.
And I know you got one letter in particular from somebody
that meant a lot to you?
Yeah.
Yes, so I'm hearing from all kinds of people over time.
I got this letter in the mail from someone
that I don't even know who the person is
or what they're going through.
And like got a little card that says, you make a difference.
This is the actual letter.
The actual letter.
And it says, be the reason someone believes in the goodness
of people
and that kind of just let
and says you are the reasons sir.
And so that motivates me just to keep it going.
I got this t-shirt like made on her behalf,
whoever it was and I wear it.
Ahhh, I love it, and what was her name?
Her name is Sloan.
(audience applauding)
I have a followup from the letter.
Here is the woman who wrote you this letter.
Her name is Sloan.
And roll the tape.
Take a look right there.
Hi Brian, I'm Sloan Sheraton Thomas.
I'm the person who wrote you a note
about, "I Want to Mow Your Lawn",
your service that you're providing during this pandemic.
And I was truly inspired
and wanted to appreciate you for that.
I think you're amazing.
And I'm also just appreciate
how much your business has grown since then.
And thank you for doing all of this for old people
and veterans, and let's stay in touch and become pen pals.
That would be great.
(audience applauding)
Oh my god.
I promised I wouldn't cry.
(Drew laughing)
You would.
t's like unbelievable.
(Ross laughing)
Nice to know she is real.
Put a face to the mysterious angel.
Unbelievable.
She changed the world.
Well, I want to donate $5,000 to Your Mow Your Lawn.
I Want to Mow Your Lawn.
I love it, and I love you, Brian Schwartz.
You're just so amazing.
Thank you so much.
It's just amazing, just to be here, just so amazing.
So thank you.
Everybody go to thedrewbarrymoreshow.com
to learn more about,
I Want to Mow Your Lawn.
(soft upbeat music)